hello everyone and welcome to round six
of the ftx crypto cup uh it is a
brilliant brilliant attacking game that
looks like it was taken from a basically
an attacking manual a manual that says
how to how to attack in chess when your
opponent breaks one too many opening
principles and not just opening
principles but the principles in general
and even though that someone could be
world champion magnus carlson now let's
uh check out what happened here it is
the first game of the match it's still
rapid so now you guys know everything uh
there is to know uh let's see the movies
aliza has the white pieces and he opens
with e4 sorry about that
uh and magnus replies with the karo khan
defense and that is pawn to c6 we have
knight to f3 d5 and now knight the c3 so
all it is a declining the usual way uh
displayed um this is a sort of an
off-beat way of meeting the karo khan we
have queen to a5 by magnus and now there
are only a handful of games that had
this exact same position on the board uh
for example uh one was uh
between lawrence trent and admiral where
e capture sandify was played c
characters and then or rather no queen
to a2 was played preparing queen to be
five the idea being that after captures
captures white can trade queens with
queen to b5 check but here uh alireza
deviates from that and he plays bishop
that's not a bishop he plays bishop to
e2 uh we have d characters on e for
knight captures and bishop to f5 much
like you would in normal karaoke knight
to g3 bishop to g6 and now there is a
game where a3 was played in 2019 between
charles monroy and jordan van forest
where uh fun forest was able to win this
but here we have castles by alireza and
it is not as of move seven that we have
a completely new game so let's see how
magnus reads this knight to d7 we have
pawn to d4 and pawn to e6 now uh and
alireza
took some time for his next move but not
as much as magnus did he played knight
to h4 and here magnus started laughing a
bit as you can pretty much see them all
the time on the cameras he was uh either
he was amused with this move or he
didn't know uh
if it was good for white maybe
it looks so silly that he didn't even
check it when preparing this line uh
point being that uh why would why would
white ever capture this uh white castle
early and if you capture on g6 maybe h
captures and g6 opens up the
h5 for the rook you can play bishop to
d6 put the bishop into the attack bring
the queen over uh to the h file so it
looks like you shouldn't be able to do
this so he spent some two and a half
maybe even three minutes um pondering on
this position and he decided to play
bishop to d6 and why not the knights are
looking very odd here so alireza
continues with c4 now we have queen back
to d8 now this comes with tempo as the
knight here is hanging and now alireza
just captures with knight captures and
g6 now i will show you one fun line that
is possible here uh specifically uh
because the bishop on d6 is undefended
and that is pawn to d5 it is similar to
what alvireza played
decided to capture on g6 first but now
uh you are uh offering the knight here
and it's uh well it's a question what do
you what do you play here now because
you either allow white to capture on e6
which kind of messes up your pawn
structure in front of the king or you
accept the challenge queen captures on
h4 now the d captures on e6 attacking
the knight and the bishop here and the
ones the queen helps out with the
defense e captus on d7 with check and it
seems like this shouldn't be all that
great for black but still let's say
queen captures on d7 rookie one now
threatens all sorts of nasty discoveries
97 queen to d4 attacking g7 and now best
for black would be bishop to b4 so if
played uh you know
properly uh should be uh in equalish
position but white should always be
better rook to d1 check sidestepping
this uh attack and white is uh ahead in
development so white will be a little
bit better here but okay alright as i
went for knight captures on g6 he
invites magnus to attack him opens up
carlson's h file h captures on g6 and
now he executes d5 with the thread of
captures and then the bishop will be
hanging so queen to h4 magnus happily
accepts this he goes for checkmate queen
captures an h2 will be checkmate h3 now
inviting bishop captures and g3 but if
you allow this uh then uh you're you
know
you might as well resign if you go for
this captures and captures then alireza
just gets all the development he needs
bishop f4
or even before capturing you might even
capture on e6 once captures captures and
now go for this bishop to f4 idea attack
the queen once the queen moves bishop g4
and look at this bishop bear as nicely
slicing
all the way there queen controlling uh
queen controlling the d file rook
controlling the f file there is no way
uh the the black king can survive this
so of course uh he didn't go for that he
played e captures on d5 he opens up the
e file and now c captures on d5 now alex
is saying all right i'm gonna capture
here and then where are you castling
with your king and okay magnus agrees
with this he plays pawn to c5 it's an
ugly move to make but what you're going
to do and now alerissa plays the
beautiful quante a4 preparing pawn to a5
and then he wants to bring the rook into
the game via rook to a4 as this will be
attacking the black queen here so magnus
stops this with pawn to a5 but maybe
this was one of those uh cases where
it's better to just allow your opponent
to you know accomplish what he wants to
do uh then than stopping it because now
alireza has this spectacular bishop to
b5 and now
there's no good move you can make for
magnus rook to e1 check is coming you
you would like the castle queen side
although if you castle queenside how are
you defending your queen side bishop d2
goes after a5 once you defend it look at
this queen b3 and now bishop the c6 is
coming uh bishop captures on a5 there's
all sorts of nasty maneuvers here that
black will be unable to stop so instead
after bishop to b5 magnus plays knight
to f6 he continues development but now
alireza says uh you will not be castling
this game sir delivers rook to e1 with
check
of course you can block with the knight
as the knight is spinned so king the d8
by magnus and now comes rook to a3 here
alireza
finds a brilliant brilliant maneuver or
of how to further harass carlson's queen
he wants to play rook to c3 rook to c4
and kick away the queen as you can see
that the queen knight bishop are all
controlling uh very important squares
here so basically you're gonna force the
black queen completely all the way back
so rook to e8 magnus wants to trade down
and now rook captures an e8 you could
ignore this with bishop to e3 as black
white is controlling more space but all
it is that goes for a very concrete line
captures captures and
goes for what he decided rook to see
three now rook to c4 is coming and this
is uh probably magnus's last opportunity
to play queen to d4 before the queen is
just kicked all the way back uh or
offering a queen trade and now for
example if rook to d3 then you go back
queen to h4 but now at least uh the
white rook will not be able to harass
you but magnus instead uh after this
rook the c3 idea violet is a place king
to d8 he unpins now okay knights to e5
will be possible uh but alireza is just
faster rook to c4 attacks the queen
queen all the way back to h8 and now
bishop the g5 not just pinning the king
here as now the knight cannot move but
also claiming the h4 square for the rook
now this queen
is really just getting kicked around the
the entire board so knights to b6
finally attacking this rook now comes
rook to h4 we have queen to f8 and now
knight to e4 putting pressure on the
knight here uh and uh
there's just again no good way to defend
if you play something like bishop to f7
then d6 traps the bishop it's uh it's
just a massacre so here magnus sidesteps
with the king once again he has to allow
the capture on f6 knight captures g
captures bishop captures now threatening
rook to h8 to this wins the queen and
the game so king the c7 and now we have
queen to d2 alireza could play uh rook
to h8 but uh
he can still improve his position before
actually capturing the queen so queen to
c8 and now rook to h7 just going after
the f7 pawn and here magnus finds
nothing better than uh to trade the
queen for for the rook and bishop so he
goes rook to g8 he invites alireza to
play rook to h8 and alireza happily goes
for this rook daytrade queen captures
bishop captures we have rook captures
now it's bishop and queen against the
magnus's knight bishop and rook so it
still might be playable but after queen
captures on a5 there's just not
a
whole lot to hang on to so rook to h4
and now queen back to e1 we have knights
to d7 now comes g3 kicking away the rook
uh you can capture here but then we play
some like king king to g2 so basically
it's important just to not allow any uh
action here on the h2 square so rook
back to h8 and now queen to a5 with
check magnus blocks this with queen back
to c3 rook captures an h3 and now
uh ali is a place queen to g7 and he was
in this position and move 36 that magnus
cause and resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here f7 pawn is
falling then everything falls and
there's just no compensation to continue
playing this so truly a spectacular feat
of of attacking chess magnus tried a
weird variation against elireza he
probably mixed something up um but even
in this line that he sort of mixed up
there were uh a lot of ways where he
could have you know continued playing
the moves that we've shown uh for some
reason uh he just uh it just didn't go
his way and for some reason he kept
laughing for the entire game ever since
this uh
this move by all it is a night stage for
here he started laughing and then he
just laughed for the entire game it's
like um
uh i don't know why some some people
were saying that he was listening to
monty python's uh on on his headphones
uh it could also just be that he you
know was laughing at the position if you
guys have any more insight into this do
share in the comments so everyone else
can improve their vast knowledge uh so
yeah that's the game uh first game of
the match alireza versus magnus hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank uh
michael sakarias heshla.com standish
company llc uh and brian enriquez for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the ftx crypto cup until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day